у робочій групі культура петербурзьку
діалог по але і тривожний на вістря нас
зустрічає око біля місця на ноги
вмовляла на лиж а конкретніше спині
проекти нам потрібно ряд уват і на
тільки саму культуру нам потрібно ряд
уват і культур не видно сина між нашим
околицями
до новітньої чумової панелі сильно без
політиків вид політики у багатії
політикам культур не дитячі на під
ремені на поки що його не домагайся інший
the culture не зв'язується з фарою
конфронтації я не з петербурзькою
діалогу форуму громадянських сус пісні
мочені русі були фактично заморожені
через дружбу живністю диво конфлікту на
сході україни їх вчений прикиньте жовтня
у потсдамі черв'яні форми все-таки
будете надій на полив шині ситуації мало
ситуацій небезпечної ситуації вона безтурботна
для нас був блеф шайби політично
ситуація була пк росію
олл-ін в боці ваш шматок за те, що ми не
можемо роботі того що хочемо за раз на
адже більше проекті в перу бітних 2 вони
а раніше я ж проектів співпраці
чим раніше навіть культура це та культура
цілий місця які треба педро water
станемо культура завжди проти лану
в руки холодної зими
Європи з курганів так називається
виставка в трилогія якубу таїться
завершить йому за ченці
якщо від загрози та меру вінки в центрі біля
води залізти на дуба зоря стильну
європейської цивілізації латини локи
успіхи завантажуються губи sea на тлі
через хвору ситуацію на модності розвитку
контакті з москвою не меч і не
розгулу від та захисних настроїв та on the
культурного вандалізму псами руси самих
тих вив і накул в ермітажі засідав ідея
чий культури за кілька 100 метрів
вандали зруйнували барельєф зображенням
федора шаляпіна в ролі мефістофелю вин
впав і все в забезпеченні був із кістки
адже будемо нити нові церкви так
ось для таких маржа ігілівських штук у
нас доходить ситуація на прийом на по
велика ризику я незабаром дуже aquel кістки
проекті біля засіки та захисних проектів та
ки приїжджає сюди
і без того непросту ситуацію повернути
потрібні легко розлучатися із захисним
екраном і через варту ніби славу
аганті спливу обидва побої ви не музей у с
тієї виставки на захід через загрозу
арешту експонаті qs прав укусу
трендової музою не сфері вже всі я
конфліктуючи з Україною і так колекція
скіфського золота з кримою предмету по
річці ведмедик і вам там вузьку
дасі завищується у нідерландах